tell us a mobile sensor network data
collection system the idea is we put a
little bit of hardware in cars this
hardware consists of a Linux box and
some sensors and then we use this data
that we've collected from the cars to
answer some interesting questions about
the world so we synthesize data from a
bunch of cars together in order to do
things like give a users a picture of
what traffic in the city probably looks
like we have a range of sensors that are
deployed in the cars all of the cars
include a GPS a global positioning
system as well as a Wi-Fi radio that
they can use for getting data off of the
cars other sensors that we put on some
of the cars include accelerometers which
can do things like measure the quality
of the ride or the surface of the road
as the car drives over it so that for
example you can detect vibrations or
bumps as the car hits them we in the
cartel project we have several different
ways of transmitting data off the cars
and one of the things we've one of the
technologies we've been working on is
developing different sort of means of
data transmission in the most basic
version of data transmission is just to
use a cell phone so this is somebody has
a cellular data plan they connect the
cell phone up to the car they connect a
wireless data a wireless data card up to
the Linux boxes in the car then use that
to transmit information off and one of
the things that we spend a lot of time
developing in the project is technology
to use Wi-Fi part of the technology
we've developed is to allows cars as
they drive by these wireless access
points to very quickly associate with
the access points and transmit little
bits of information every time they see
one of these access points that's open
and available for access as the cars are
driving along they're transmitting this
data off and they with what happens is
that they transmit it to a server or
portal that's running on a machine at
MIT and that portal was in charge of
taking all this data and synthesizing it
together in order to present a sort of
global view of sort of what's going on
in the world or what these sensors cards
are observing about the world typically
this data gets put into a sort of a
visualization that gets overlaid on top
of a map and this users can then browse
this visualization in order to learn
various things about what's going on
inside the world we have a range of
different applications that we've
developed so that the first application
is in the simplest one is
one that allows users to browse their
own driving information so you may be
interested for example in comparing the
amount of time that it takes for you to
drive from home to work on various
different routes so you can compare your
freeway drives - you're not freeway
drives if you have several different
routes from your house to work or from
your work day house other applications
that do certain more interesting things
that combine lots of data from different
cars together include one that we call
the pothole Patrol which is an
application where we use these
accelerometers on the car they're
measuring the quality of the ride to
detect where potholes are in the city of
Boston and categorize them in terms of
their severity a third application that
we spent a lot of time developing is a
traffic portal so the idea here is that
we use the cars as they're driving along
we can learn things about how fast they
were able to drive on every road and
then for each road segment each little
piece of road like for example Mass Ave
in front of MIT we can compute a
distribution of the delays that your car
is experience when they were driving on
that the first goal is to explore the
use of cop cars or mobile nodes as
sensing devices so how can we use these
mobile things in order to measure the
world and so it's about one goal is
about just developing the technology
that's needed to get data off of these
cars that are moving around in the world
and to bring it back to a server and to
synthesize it and store it together and
some of the challenges there include
things like dealing with variable
connectivity that the cell phones you
know cut in and out as you drive around
or there are here is a continuous
wireless connectivity available
everywhere so one goal is sort of a
technology goal the other goal is an
application goal which is to develop
some of these use these cars in order to
develop applications that are sort of
new and different and enable things that
will help people besides computer
scientists this traffic portal that I
mentioned is an example of something
that everybody could take advantage of
people anybody would be interested in
knowing what the best route to take from
A to B is obviously things like MapQuest
and Google Maps have a huge uptake and
adding traffic to those would just
increase their value so one of the
things we're doing in order to bring the
cost of this box down is we're looking
at solutions that
include smaller amounts of hardware
inside of a car because we think that
hardware cost as a barrier to entries
and that we think will allow us to
produce a piece of hardware that goes
into the cars that maybe only costs 30
or 40 dollars per car and which would be
something that and we think an average
person might be willing just to put in
their car order to benefit from this
technology
you